WK & z
oh yeah it's gonna be a big one tonight
[ __ ] slinging dick and giving up
bubblegum
you know I'm saying that's the motto of
the date by that [ __ ]
it
and the garden a good and evil it's 3:00
Thursday [ __ ] it's a beautiful
day to be alive November 23rd we're here
with with the uncle joey's and full of
that today I got a meeting jujitsu I got
the [ __ ] Irvine improv eight o'clock
[ __ ] getting your car and four
and head down there we're going deep
tonight you understand me 200 milligrams
we're gonna break our record tonight if
I pass out on stage I have an anxiety
attack so [ __ ] be this Thanksgiving
some pilgrims gravis there's some good
ones head got cut off your [ __ ]
turkey tomorrow you might as well go
deeper than the deepest beat but enough
with the [ __ ] stories today we'll
take a different perspective Gino from
speed weed if you're in LA for all your
delivery needs ain't nobody out there
delivering it like Gino this weed a
[ __ ] king you could leave his little
conjurer if I could take this you open
this [ __ ] up you take the filter
off because who needs a [ __ ] filter I
wanted to go straight to the bottom of
the [ __ ] lung here that cost that's
30 years a PhD cough
why not when I spoke up the number with
you guys just to change it up a little
bit you know I'm saying little takes out
de Morocco
stuck-up the AAP [ __ ] still got some
other weave going in there by [ __ ]
with the Russian president and that said
it's all about you and your family in
next two days people you're giving
thanks for the slightest [ __ ] thing
you understand me the days you overlook
every goddamn day that's why I give
thanks for my two feet hitting the floor
in the morning I give thanks when I'm
washing my [ __ ] I'm giving thanks when
I'm eating breakfast you know how
[ __ ] fortunate we are mmm even if
you're broke you're alive you got your
help you ever see my man Craig Michael
on the [ __ ] wheelchair you ever see
the smile of his face you understand me
there's nothing like a smile on your
face [ __ ] but that's it the
podcast up you got Rudy Sarzo was on
Monday Jorge Perez we got a great
[ __ ] week of podcasts for you when
you travel you traveling today let me
tell you some keep your eyes okay every
rule number one if you don't got to go
don't go [ __ ] all that [ __ ] you've got a
busted mark and get that [ __ ]
communist Turkey but you know you got to
see your family because that's all you
debt is my first real Thanksgiving with
a family that little girl I got my wife
was better than me even if whatever
that's all you gotta give thanks for is
that 3 people that means something in
your life three people it's gotta be
three [ __ ] that change you
everything I got off the phone are you
gonna call my seventh grade teacher then
I'll call my eyes and teach all the
people that changed my [ __ ] life get
a call from me today understand me I
want to thank God for these
[ __ ]
well that's it we got smoking and join
the lifelike [ __ ] family you're with
me I'm with you and they want to be what
else but they can't because they're too
fake they got a feather well Hilary said
who gives a [ __ ] when Hillary says when
I'm with Joey sit [ __ ]
I'm listening to what the nude man said
I'm saying and that's it that's tight
but most important we got each other I'm
just [ __ ] holiday so I'll be doing
videos - my [ __ ] around smoking
briefie turkey roll escape and whatever
the [ __ ] I'm doing you guys know about
it cuz I want to be with your
Thanksgiving that's the type of [ __ ]
Puerto Rican I am I don't give a [ __ ]
about Trump Trump's got all these
immigrants and [ __ ] and I'm saying even
the Chandler [ __ ] they don't play the
Arab music live no more whatever check
they know that Trump's coming with a
[ __ ] neck but you know what even if
Trump is showing up you got Olivia flop
in life play like a savage and [ __ ] em
all up Diaz who gives a [ __ ] about
probation I got the time standing on my
[ __ ] head understand me
[ __ ] with me [ __ ] with me Coco [ __ ]
anyway
waiting should we do a vault - out of
respect you know we do with you this
thing here this is just an aperitif for
flavor
anyway I want to tell you [ __ ]
something from the bottom of my heart
but not you guys that have dick tomorrow
have that day but before I bite into
that turkey I'm gonna give thanks to all
you [ __ ] from talking Laird
okey spooky
that's a bobby crystal - [ __ ] crystal
my girl from Utah milking cows - the
whole thing this family to [ __ ] turn
Michael - rj struck joe the [ __ ]
jeremy slag off or you [ __ ]
ain't got my back for real you don't
think I forgot I forgot the giant [ __ ]
Larry David they've been with the church
since day one my man showed your take of
his girlfriend [ __ ] an ambulance
listen I don't have a lot of [ __ ]
tools I'm not good looking
come my family's [ __ ] men's I marked
but one thing I got is loyalty and
[ __ ] hard [ __ ] up there and you want
to learn - you you all live to be 50
[ __ ] 3 and have nothing and be a
[ __ ] animal or you've made is loyalty
and heart and no the [ __ ] you go bonza
everything else falls into place
loyalty in heart got me here in the stem
everything else was sucking my dagger no
talent I got zero talent the talent is
the loyalty I am I didn't get my mom a
lot being the aya oh yeah dear aunt
their son giving well his soldiers done
I smoked a bowl out of respect and I'll
let you go back to your lives are your
[ __ ] flight or whatever the [ __ ]
you're doing right now
but besides that man listen it's a
beautiful day we could be six feet under
but we're still swinging dick whether
you got a dollar get back in it two
hundred thousand you know I'm saying you
gotta keep them guessing right there
like you got 200 G's in your pocket
there's a [ __ ] take a chance Columbus
did [ __ ] [ __ ] ass smoking ball one
ball between us like family what does
this type of [ __ ] and that's it we'll
call it David you know my heart is that
my head is that I cracked a lot of
[ __ ] stupid jokes but the
[ __ ] that I've been hanging out
for years you know an artist and that's
the most important thank God gave you an
extra gift see these other idiots they
jump on these other [ __ ] these
people are kinda hard these people ain't
got nothing but they buy into it you
guys that brand with Joey you know how
to buy into heart I saw [ __ ] the face
[ __ ] he hangs out with nobody hang out
with bushes and trees and [ __ ] cats
oh yeah that's it I love you [ __ ]
without you I have nothing and nothing
understand me boom we take over this
[ __ ] day
I'm gonna be [ __ ] slapping them all
away down the street that's what you do
in your whole life to you just let them
you just sit like hey even an old dog
gets a warm spot on the sidewalk all you
gotta do is sit and wait and keep doing
it done boom your star comes up now you
start shooting people my god he an 85
they know the [ __ ] you run away and
that's it nice day 8 o'clock tonight
Irvine improv be the Beast I don't give
a [ __ ] if you got a chip in and take a
helicopter you don't want to miss this
tonight Steve's the most releasing the
CD Lisa I add on a thousand two thousand
milligrams up on stage and we shoot
spitballs out anything
listen happy Thanksgiving to you and
your families I wish I could be there
with you and smoke a joint
don't grandmother suck my dick man I
can't be everywhere at once
I love you guys thank you for the love
and support you've given me over the
[ __ ] years we're showing these
[ __ ] is one things understanding
December 8th see so TV unsure socially
unacceptable to name it especially all
right I need you [ __ ] to
download that I didn't listen to me I
need you guys great it's free Joey did
just press and coat Joey go over the hey
you fill out your name your email you
give him the [ __ ] passport down ahead
you put in Joey you had to three months
for free it's [ __ ] what the 23rd you
got to January 20 bill you go watch my
special injectable for my face a
thousand times I read listen Happy
Thanksgiving to you your family's be
safe
keep your eyes open at the airport these
[ __ ] is their time right not a
rule
people when I'm looking to ruin nobody
we're looking to [ __ ] had quality to
life concept I love you stay black but
make somebody's date today
boy it didn't get my mother not being
down I will get to know Leroy yo I love
you [ __ ]